what's up guys look what we have here
today we have the 52 toys transforming
teenage mutant ninja figures these are
awesome toys out of china you might not
have seen them much but they have made
very good license stuff let's look at
what we have here power loader from
aliens and we've got the alien queen as
well right now they've gotten the ninja
turtles license these are official stuff
from nickelodeon themselves you look at
it they have the branding up here so
this is something legit that everyone
should really check out if you've never
had 52 toys they actually make really
cool transforming blocks that go from
raptors or gorillas into small little
blocks and this time these are much
bigger as well i've had some time with
them so let's go on and check them out
now that we have them all in hand just
want to really give you guys a look what
all these boxes look like the cool part
about the 52 toys that i mentioned
earlier they all come in a very boxy
shape so
particularly for the teenage mutant
ninja turtles you can see they can go
from actually a figure a turtle mode and
then they go into a truck
and they go in a container and then
lastly they have a box so let's get into
it let's check out raphael first rafael
is the only one that is very different
compared with saying michelangelo
donald tello as well and leonardo
raphael has a very much comic book look
especially when it comes to his eyes and
the iris and the pupils you can see that
he has no irises if i'm not wrong irises
at all and this is definitely the
similar stuff that you will enjoy if you
were a fan of the comic book okay let's
get into it let's open up rafael first i
really want to really open up each box
to let you guys see what are the
contents in each oh okay his size came
out here
then just put this one side put the
boxes i'm just gonna slowly unbox
everything for you guys to take a look
to get real good sense of what each of
these figures are i'm gonna put them up
here
so you can actually have some look at
all these
look at the articulation guys shoulder
we've got the elbow as well
elbow articulation
and wrist
this is awesome head wise does he go up
and down quite a bit um small tilts i
would say
small tilts he's not able to actually
articulate on the waist unfortunately
you can see that but he moves quite a
bit around his hip
his hip here
and the knee
and the last bit here his ankles pretty
good poses so you can actually have very
very dynamic poses these figures are not
very heavy so i'm pretty sure you can
have a very good stand to actually get
them closed up so this is what we have
rafael here we have the box
let's put him one side
and let's get to the rest as well
i think my favorite is michelangelo he's
the party dude i think he's the easy
sale for anyone who has grown up in the
90s and loved the ninja turtles in
general let's check out what they have
here
this instruction manual
more instructions here
mike angelo guys this is awesome love
the color we've got his box as well and
his nunchucks
let's look at the new trucks
wow cool
we have the leader of the operation this
is leonardo here
leonardo's not really my favorite he's a
bit of uh
i don't know
yeah yeah stickler for rules it's not
very chill that's why i think
michael angelo is more my kind of person
you know looks good she isn't he's they
all come in different shades of green it
seems
so if you look at it right um
michelangelo looks the most comical in
some ways in the green here and
yeah the detail is awesome different
face expression here he is fierce look
at that xeno okay let's get them
standing you see how they are able to
stand so easily not much support as well
his twin swords
fold away
look at that i'm pretty sure um has part
of um all 52 toys all these accessories
right have a purpose and a place between
their figure itself so you don't have to
worry about wow when am i going to keep
this or put it in the ziploc bags will i
lose them you can put them all onto the
turtle itself the brains of the
operation and we have donatello
look at that it's a different color here
for donald teller checked out
donatello's bowl stuff as well this is
pretty cool and i'm pretty sure you can
actually take it apart let's look at it
okay there we go
it goes into three sections and he's
gonna be hidden somewhere within
donatello's body look at all these sizes
here pretty awesome um i would say
comparative to all the action figures
they played as a kid and
eventually all of them will actually
convert into a small little cube
converting the truck or container and
they can combine as well so if you have
the full set you get two sets of trucks
but honestly here i will be keeping them
in this position here i think this is
why it looks the most and it's very good
in terms of the design itself and it
doesn't feel cheap at all guys this
plastic is awesome on the rear if you
can see here sadly we've got to put the
copyright uh corporate attacks
not very cool let's get to transforming
them this video is brought to you by
secret lab here at geek culture we love
our circulators especially the all-new
2022 titan evo with its revamped 4-way
lumbar system for enhanced back support
if bu leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea
then consider the all-new soft weave
even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colours
including this lovely frost blue the
tyson evo is even magnetized along the
hit pillar to stick on the headrest of
course there are even more new features
so do check them out at secretlab.co
one thing if you guys have been buying
any third party toys that are not
officially licensed you realize that the
quality of the manuals is actually
pretty rubbish
i'll be honest here 52 toys has done a
brilliant job all the details of being
able to transform it from point to point
is spot on they have specific little
parts
that color codes in some ways what
really needs to be done and what needs
to be transitioned
from step one to step two transforming
it from this these modes here you can
turn turtle form into let's say the
container or the truck i've tried
transforming rafael for quite a few
times already has my practice turtle and
it takes me about roughly seven minutes
per transformation 36 steps only just to
get to the box mode but every step of
the way is a pleasure
and let's get to transforming
35 steps
not too hard very good instructions
honestly it's really a joy and a
pleasure when you're transforming these
guys okay
on tap d
you see the body here part here untapped
and then you see the transformation
beginning already bringing the knob
then you can see the arms here
out really nicely
very nice tension to it
you can see that the tabs
open up
here
and we can just lock it in like this
all very elegant it holds in pretty
nicely there's no click to it
it's pretty good
okay we are ready at step 10.
you can see this is the insides of the
you saw that initially this is the chest
the hands fall in very nicely
into this part
let's get dollar talos raphael's head
away
there we have it tucked into his shell
itself and it's very nice and stuck
it's very hard to see if the square is
coming into place right now but
trust me it gets there pretty fast
and already in step 27 time to get the
legs apart very standard if you have
very familiar transformers getting the
licks and splitting them apart is a very
normal
normal transformation technique
we have the legs let's look at the other
side
just bring it up this way
and it all taps really nicely locks it
all in
okay after very quick transformation
this is how the rafael figure looks like
as a block
you can see they can see the elements of
the shell
in the chest they're all still there but
it's all very nicely tucked away
i'm loving this
does not look like anything like a
square
takes a lit quite a bit of imagination
to
to think it through but here's my most
favorite part once you remove
the
weapons into this parts here
they all tuck away nicely into the shell
itself on the figurine if you look at it
it's all the
tabs and you just put it in here
there we go
the sides
go in onto the back the pointy edges
the last bit here they go to the bottom
guys
and there you go
now we've got to get the rest of the
four turtles into the same form but
before that i'm going to show you how to
change it from your box figure into a
trunk so from here
down
you get the windows
okay there we go you can see the license
plate here says ninja turtles nin here
are the wheels you can see here the
wheels you just need to push them up
there we have it the fully converted
truck mode for raphael i'm gonna do this
for the rest of the turtles and let's
combine them together to see how it
actually looks like
mikey here with his nunchucks
there we have it mikey right now in
truck mode
let's get leonardo as cargo and then
let's wrap things up
okay
now we have gotten leonardo into box
mode i think what's cool here is his
swords his swords
fold downwards
and once they fall downwards let's see
how they tuck away into the box mode
itself
before oh once you fold them away you're
supposed to even remove them
remove the blade from the sheath
from the handle
and
these swords go into the back
okay guys big critic here
leonardo isn't that hot when it comes to
putting his weapons in no issues with
the other turtles but i think we know
that the tabs aren't that
that responsive or does not fit that
well
that being said it's not too bad of a
deal i think oh well
most toys don't even have this function
here
and it's very hard to tab it in
unlike the other rest
and he's done
he is in
carriage mode ready so let's attach him
to
michael angelo
to get a look at how
the complete
pizza truck
mode looks like
and there we have it look at that
combined into one piece two turtles in
one
this is very awesome
it's not the prettiest because you can
see the panels they are not actually
perfect yet
let's go on to final thoughts guys and
let me wrap up my review of the 52 toys
teenage mutant ninja turtles personally
you should really go out and get these
these are a label of love from the fossa
52 toys and i really love them you'll
look great on any shelf they cost about
36 usd if you're a fan of teenage mutant
ninja turtles do not hesitate let me
know in the comment section below if you
have any thoughts comments about these
figures i'll be happy to answer them for
you the last thing you can really do for
us is really liking commenting and
sharing this video and most importantly
do remember to subscribe
it really goes a long way and this is
gerald signing off cowabunga dudes
[Music]
you